- You ever see somebody
eat something so good
that they turn into a shaman?
- I'm just curious is it,
is it gonna taste salty?
- I guess I'm completing
the authenticity of my blackness today.
- Not bad, but it's not like
super flavorful, either.
- Flavor's good, though.
I mean, not too much seasoning going on.
Not bland.
It's like, right in the middle.
- It tastes soulful.
- I'm sorry, I miss ham so much.
I don't eat ham a lot,
but when I get it, I'm like, "Oh, ham!
"I missed you, friend."
- This is really good.
You got some more I can take home?
- This smells great.
It looks great.
- It like, melted,
right when it hit my tongue,
so that's a good sign,
something really good.
- You know, collards take
so damn long to like, rinse.
Oh.
You gotta clean collards right.
- Did you say coloreds?
- Collards.
- Even when given the scraps,
like, Black people know
how to make a dollar
out of 15 cents.
- Oh, like hip hop?
- Oh, yeah.
- Uh, it's a foot.
It's a legit foot.
- [Woman] It's so fatty, ugh!
- Suck on the feet, you know?
- Yeah, suck it.
That's the way you eat soul food.
- This is so gummy.
- Mm-mm.
- I'm not feeling this at all.
- I like it.
- This looks so f-(bleep) good.
- This is like the Black
person's, like, cup of noodles,
when you in college.
It's grits.
- [Man in Red] Yeah.
- I don't know.
They're all right.
- Mm-mm.
- Sugar on grits, by itself.
- I do salt and butter, not sugar.
That's disgusting.
Eat Cream of Wheat, you crazy people.
- Oh.
- It's warm!
- Wow.
- It's so good.
- It reminds me of a toaster strudel.
I mean, this is 10 times
better than that, but like--
- Hell, yeah.
- This is the only dish that you put out
that I feel compelled to finish.
- I'm sweating.
- My god, she's sweating.
- My boobs are
- [Man] She's getting, like,
sweating.
- [Man] hot flashes.
- Whoever's momma made this--
- This pleases the lip.
- Does she got a daughter?
- Definitely important.
This reminds me of, like, my family,
and like, community.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Man] Like, I might make
a phone call after this.
- When you're able to eat somebody's food,
that you know they've put love into,
it's kind of like, what, communication.
- Soul food is good sh-(bleep), man.
It's amazing.
This is definitely like the,
how Big Mama died in Soul Food,
got her foot cut off?
- It's too soon.
- Might as well, you lost your foot.
Almost burned down the house.
- I can't eat this.